من عام الى اخر ينتظر الفلسطينيون موسم
قطف الزيتون لكن ما لا ينتظرونه هو ان
يتحول هذا الموسم الى اكثر فترات العنف
والاعتداءات الدمويه تجاههم على يد
المستوطنين المحيطين بارام يشرح لنا محمد
كيف تحول يوم اجتماع العائله لقضاء اجمل
ايام العام اثناء قطف الزيتون بقريه
الساويه في نابلس الى ماساه بعد هجوم
المستوطنين المسلحين
وقتلهم عمه بلال وفق ما وثقته كاميرات
جوالاتهم لو تخنا جميع نحنا الموجودين مين
حدا
ساله بعد ما استشهد عم بطخ صار كل الناس
تخاف يقوللك يعني فش اليوم ما في كانوا
مثلا تخف الهواء اليوم لا ممكن يقتل خمسه
سته ما حدا بساله مين كله شو بتسوي ما حدا
بساله هو نموذج للارتفاع غير المسبوق
بمعدلات عنف المستوطنين ومحاولات استغلال
الظرف القائم لفرض واقع جديد وقدم المزيد
من الاراضي ليست اعتداءات المستوطنين فقط
هي التي تصاعدت وازدادت حدتها منذ بدء
الحرب على غزه فممارسة
قوات الاحتلال عشرات الاقتحامات بحثا عن
تصفهم بالمطلوبين وتتعمد تكسير المنازل
وتدميرها بشكل انتقامي لا تخطئه عين لم
تسلم منه غرفه اطفال الشاب شادي الذي
اعتقلته من منزله وتعمدت ضربه واهانته
امامهم كانوا الشباب موجودين هون اما
رفيقه ليلتها ففجر قوات الاحتلال سيارته
واطلقت عليه النار واحتجزت جثمانه بعد
استشهاده
بين اييها طبعا لما طلعوا الشباب فوق
واجوا يهربوا طبعا بامكانهم يعتقلوا
اعتقال لانه في جيش من فوق وفي جيش موقين
الا
انهم طخو طبعا وانا بشهاده بعد الجيران
هنا اخوي لما نزلوه هون هي اثار الدم
موجوده اللي له هنا كان يحكي وكان عايش
وانا بتهمهم
باغتياله اكثر من 2500 فلسطيني اعتقلهم
جنود الاحتلال من منكتب الماي في الضفه
الغربيه تعمدوا تصويرهم في حالات مذله
والتنكيل بهم اثناء الاعتقال وداخل
المعتقلات واذاقهم الوانا غير مسبوقه من
العذاب كما يقول عبد القادر الذي افرج عنه
قبل ايام فقط التعذيب تبعهم اول سؤال تبوس
علم الصله بعرف ضربوك واك الضريب المبرح
تعذيب كلياته مناطق حساسه اقسم بالله ولو
ويطيح الدم منك شلال ما فيش ممنوع دكتور
يكرب عليك يداويك
والشباب حلفوني بالله وانا مروح انا ماتيت
دم ما مجهت دموع انك تحاول توصل للجزيره ل
للتلفزيونات الاجتماعيه كلها توصل رسالتنا
انه نحن قاعدين بنموت بموت بطيء يقول
الفلسطينيون ان اسرائيل لا تكترث لاي
تبعات قانونيه لهذه الممارسات ولا تكلف
نفسها حتى عناء الرد على المطالبات
الدوليه بوضع حد لها لا بل انها تواصل
سياسه الاقتحامات وتدمير الشوارع والبنى
التحتيه والاجراءات الانتقاميه من سكان
الضفه الغربيه ما يزيد الضغط على اهلها
حسن مسعود ال الجزيره
جنين